hey Jenna where we going I don't know
our mom's freezing oh I know your
restart of the video Wow wait shouldn't
you know this is the beginning of the
video getting well PET SHOP woman we're
going to Palm Springs Maddy's excited
he's really hot it's supposed to be like
113 we didn't really take that into
account whenever we're like that's good
fun Springs let me get it'll be great
shaking my head smh
first off we want to see if we can get a
little lifejacket for Maddie's in case
Casey we want to teach him to swim today
think I'm patty a shark and lobster
costume it's pretty good tactic oh honey
safety babe
this is not gonna work out it's like hey
we're not going on a boat we don't need
it he's just gonna take a simple dip in
the pool and use those muscles to swim I
think I'm actually more concerned about
myself swimming from the dog we probably
should all right I got two items let's
go you have to give the baby bed make
sure you always test hot brown because
it can burn the pads
we barely made to our house in Palm
Springs it's so pretty it's actually
really really nice and Maddy so far is
in love with it it is so hot outside
like his little feet have to be so
careful she doesn't get his little
Tootsie's burn yeah it's difficult a
little place get a nice little living
room yeah I think we just went on like
laying out chillin eating some snag on
the marquee selection we only have the
lemon yeah did you get ice cream and by
any chance oh we only have dog ice cream
we might need to get ice cream though
somewhere pull super cute grades I
planned on having sort of a vacation of
no editing but that's not realistic
because I've got like five videos any
minute so I would like to show you our
raft selection first one we have is a
popsicle second one we have is a donut
and the third one which is my personal
favorite old-school NES controller
look at me I'll put on this it's a
little time I think it's time to get the
drone out
girl
we have really bad news but this is I
mean it's kind of good news this
apparently is a restricted area and you
can't fly said nope sorry you can't pick
off
I try to recalibrate it and nothing
would work so looks like they'll be no
Palm Springs drone playing hi baby
whooping so Anadyr we officially made it
as you can see I also tried to fly the
drone then it failed so apparently it's
a restricted area which is cool still a
little upset about us don't really want
to fly my drone I don't know where I can
fly it here in Palm Springs and then I
look it up see what I can see where just
can have a nice weekend just doing
nothing except I'll probably be editing
but that's fun yeah me I was fully after
dinner pretzels and gluten free cheese
crackers all right well I'm just gonna
make us something okay do you mean eggs
make all cheeses how about I make them
in the toaster oven so pan here good
luck
not sure how this place already became a
disaster we just got here it's not very
good manners to eat this side because
I'm getting this Avril well let's give
him a raspberry they tell me you're not
bad news half only before right yes
we're staying at Walmart until we do
charming he ran away I told you II ran
away Brian Randall breaking this phone
try me and ER I got a client you first
try 5:27 what I was like ooh crap I said
crap I said crab god it's beautiful
I'll give you $100 draw that back to LA
Oh too hot for that whoa
an electric one the Freestyle dirty room
it's the weight limit
there are so many Pokemon and Walmart
like this is absolutely incredible I'm
having a great day
sometimes meeting about your future do
you ever picture yourself sitting in a
Walmart in Palm Springs on the flip-flop
aisle sitting next to the displays and
playing Pokemon go definitely not
something that I would picture for
myself about crowd yeah I don't know
we're about to evolve my Charmander yeah
why not where do I get a Charmeleon up
yes then I need 100 right I need a
Charizard this just got really not fun
I'm gonna go to bed I think it's not a
clock actually I'm exhausted so see you
guys tomorrow
my entire it's okay and it's sitting rot
you want to give it a good stab Matt Oh
No